tout a basculé pour vol de treize ans
après la mort de votre père vous avez
commencé à boire à vous droguez vous
avez complété avec des médicaments ce
qui fait un sacré cocktail est ce que
comment vous avez fait pour vous en
sortir d'abord déjà déjà d'accepter
parce que déjà faut déjà accepté qu'on a
un problème c'est que c'est pas le tout
mais le comprendre il faut l'accepter et
après ça j'essaie d'avoir de l'aide est
donc en fait moi je dis souvent si je
prends pas du tout cas pour une
généralité
je dis pas que c'est parce que tu fume
un joint que tu finis avec une seringue
dans le bras
je n'ai pas dit ça moi mais comme on a
parlé de la prévention on veut savoir
quelles sont les possibilités qui sont
offertes ça a été mon cas moi j'ai
commencé par le shit je finis à 2
grammes d'héroïne par jour
en fait tout dépend pourquoi est ce que
les gens consomment camp et c'est pour
ça monsieur je suis partagé par rapport
à ça effectivement quand je vois comment
tu mets ton panneau je comprends tout à
fait parce que lille c'est pareil moyen
des fois je suis je dit oui il faut
légaliser
c'est un pan enfin voilà il ya des
problèmes et que le côté quand j'ai des
parents qui m'appelle avec un gamin de
13 ans qui fument de la beuh depuis deux
ans qui fut rien de sa vie qui
complètement à côté de la plaque
là je me dis ouais j'ai du mal à lâcher
du mal par rapport à ça et sur lequel
serait notre option qu'il allait sur le
trafic le problème il y sommes c'est
qu'effectivement qui cette manne
financière tout ce qui est autour de ça
ils vont vendre quoi les gens enfin ceux
qui qui qui qui vend qui vivent de sa
guise de ça ils vont vendre quoi ils
vont faire quoi ils vont s'arrêter du
jour au lendemain de faire du bizness
séoul c'est génial on n'y croit pas
franchement alors que modibo porter
l'information qui est quand même au
coeur du système excusez-moi pas dire ce
qu'on veut donc j'ai beaucoup de respect
pour pau pour toi ne qui a pas de souci
là dessus mais il est au coeur du
système en 2020 2021 qu'est ce qu'il me
dit faut arrêter de raconter des bêtises
si on a on arrête le cannabis ils vous
demandent de l'héroïne de la coque ni me
dit me le font déjà
le mec qui te fait ce qu'elle dit c'est
pas vrai ça va pas sortir des cages
d'escalier les trafiquants vont rester
la même demande
il ya des gens qui vont des du site
voilà qui vendent et du shit de qui
vendent et de la coupe du monde et des
romanes ans et les mêmes personnes qui
vendent des produits point barre et bien
sûr c'est aussi simple que ça c'est pour
moi le cannabis ils ont qualifié 10 et
celles qui ont ôté leur voile gentiment
assis sur un produit qu'elle débarque
lui sert beaucoup plus important à la
cocaïne comme les radicaux maison fait
ta mine comme si c'est si vous vous
devez faire la balance entre les
avantages de la légalisation et les
inconvénients ce que vous pensez quand
même que ça peut améliorer un peu la
situation je ne vous y croyez c'est pas
ça qui empêchera les yamada les
consommer c'est le fait d'aller braver
des interdits pas assez facilement ce
qui est interdit par des qataris est
aussi libre a pu un interdit aussi
légaliser les jeunes mineurs non mes
deux compagnons légaliser
en fait on comparer les lésions trafic
et une loi d amnistie pour tous les
petits dealers qui se sont recyclés et
de fait et ça a marché c'est bien sur
quoi de mes notes dans l'économie réelle
vous avez des gens me disent que je suis
en banlieue il ya des gens qui vous
expliquent que si on arrête cette manne
financière pour les gros bonnets en gros
les habitants en bas vont devenir
pauvres et soudainement ne seront pas
quoi faire mais c'est du pipeau les gens
qui disent ah qu'ils soient élus locaux
d'ailleurs je me méfie beaucoup des élus
locaux qui ceux qui sont entrés à la
légalisation parce qu'en général c'est
que ils ont un petit entendement par en
dessous avec les trafiquants et je
trouve ça toujours c'est louche
d'habitantes d'une commune de 500 et je
vous le dis donc les élus les gens vont
l'aimer
non les gens ils pourront pas travailler
à bout puisque je n'ai pas entendu ni
bernard nyroca les auditions de là j'ai
la mission d'enquêté mené par par jean
baptiste dit les débats le président
réda de cette commission et notamment
vous avez auditionné des économistes qui
vous lisent ça n'est pas vrai c'était le
soir comme quoi d'un jugement la
banlieue va s'écrouler parce que parce
qu'en gros on aura socialiser entre
guillemets ce trafic et au fond moi la
question que je me pose aujourd'hui et
c'est ça qui m'intéresse j'aimerais
qu'on avance un peu c'est un peu la
question que tu connais si on légalise
on le fait comme en fait j'aimais mes
filles ce sera mon dernier
je me méfie beaucoup du rêve de du grand
marché qui va rapporter des milliards et
qu'on va taxer